the conditions inside the as of style uh
plants are as you say absolutely uh
horrendous and they are getting worse
all the time the humanitarian situation
is extremely dire we have seen this
being played out really almost in slow
motion we've seen things posted on
social media over the last few weeks
we've seen fighters inside who've lost
limbs others who have wounds that are
starting to rot they are gangrenous
because they can't get the
medicine and medical treatment that they
need
and of course inside with them are we
think
about 200 civilians what happens to
those people
we simply don't know at the moment they
are trying to negotiate another
ceasefire
the diplomacy on that front is faltering
we have seen after the last evacuees
managed to escape
the russians have resumed very heavy
shelling and aerial bombardment of that
plant satellite images incidentally show
the extent of the devastation and damage
whole areas of that complex have
literally been obliterated by the the
very heavy bombing now i was in zapposia
yesterday and i spoke to a number of
people who'd managed to escape and they
described
the trauma of what it was like to be
inside many of them were getting off the
buses after they arrived in the relative
safety
of the un reception point which had been
set up in a shopping center they were
confused in some cases
others didn't really know what to make
of all the waiting press they didn't
really quite understand how much their
story had captured the world's attention
but every single one of them absolutely
relieved uh to be out of there they told
me that uh
they could put up in some cases it's
hard to believe with the shelling
but it was the the big bunker busters
that really uh brought the horror home
because they you know the wall shaped in
some parts the bits that they were in
started to fall down but the concern now
of course is for those people still
trapped inside and we just do not know
at this moment whether the diplomacy
will be able to reach another agreement
for them to get out